[موسيقى]
مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم احنا النهارده
عندنا حلقه جديده في سلسله افكار الاستاذ
مع الاقتصادي والمفكر المرموق الدكتور جود
عبد الخالق طبعا كان مخططي ان احنا نستانف
الحديث معه عن افكاره وا ضاع السياسه
والاقتصاد محليا واقليميا ودوليا ولكن جاء
طوفان الاقصى وكان من الضروري ان انا
استطلع رايه في ما يجري قلت بدل ما استطلع
رايه خارج الهواء نستطلع رايه في حضور
حضراتكم مساء الخيرات معال الدكتور مساء
النور واهلا بك وبسا المشاهدين ربنا يخلي
حضرتك الطوفان الاقصى حدث
متكرر من حيث الاحتكاك والصدام ولكن
استثنائي في حجمه وبيتم تحليله على كل
المستويات العسكري والسياسي و والاجتماعي
انت حضرتك شايف الحدث ده من انه زاويه
يعني وخصوصا فيما يتعلق بالدعم المطلق
للولايات المتحده لاسرائيل ما حدث في 7
اكتوبر في راينا بيمثل نقله
نوعيه على مستوى هذا الصراع
المحدود لانه نمره واحد دائما كان الطرف
الاخر اللي هو العدو الصهيوني ياخذ زمام
المباداه زمام المباداه الان بفضل 7
اكتوبر ولازال حتى الان في الواقع انتقل
للطرف الثاني بتاعنا بفضل
مجهود المقاومه وانه ما هو حادث من جانب
اسرائيل وكل من يدعمها وعلى رسوم الولايات
المتحده هو قبيل رد الفعل واحيانا رد
الفعل غير مح مسوب نقطه مهمه جدا عشان نحط
عدونا في حجمه الحقيقي ونحط مجهودنا في
حجمه الحقيقي ا بهذا المعنى ان نحن نتحدث
عن
حلقه من المواجهات في سلسله طويله مفجات
سبقتها حلقات عده
وسيتلقى لان امريكا ليست في خنده واحده هي
وراها كل ما يسمى العالم
الغربي عمليه تجييش فتحت مخازن الذخيره
الموجوده في اسرائيل وفي غرام الاماكن
اللي كان تكون تحت تصرف اسرائيل في هذا
الظرف في الولايات المتحده وفي غيرها من
الامريك مزبوط مظبوط يعني بتتكلم على في
المنطقه في الولايات المتحده في اوروبا في
كل مكان يعني عمليه حشد في
الواقع تتجاوز ما حدث في اوكرانيا بمعاني
كثيره كيف نفهم
هذا الدعم والتاييد اللامحدود الولايات
المتحده ارسال اثنين من اكبر او اكبر
حاملات
الطائرات في الترسانه العسكريه الامريكيه
بالاضافه الى
سفن بطانيه وغيرها سؤال يعني انت تتحدث عن
اثنين وكسر
مليون اثين اين وثلا اين ونص حتى من
الفلسطينين في الواقع يعتبروا
اسرع في هذا المكان المسمى غزه وبالتالي
هل يشكلون هذه الخطوره التي تستدعي انه
امريكا ترسل حاملتي طائرات واو الى اخره
ده سؤال مهم جدا لابد ان اجابتي انا لا
طبعا يعني تهديد غزه وحتى الاطراف اللي
ممكن يعني تدخل على الخط زي حزب الله زي
حزب الله مثلا لا يستدعي مثال سؤال لماذا
وهنا بقى هنلاقي المشترك بين اللي حادث في
المنطقه واللي حادث في شرق اوروبا في
اوكرانيا تحديدا انه لو تابعنا حركه
النظام الرئسي المالي في السنوات الاخيره
هنجد منذ اندلاع الازمه الماليه العالميه
2008 حتى الان النظام الراس ما العالمي
دخل في مرحله ركود ركود معناه ايه معناه
تباطؤ معدل النمو الاقتصادي في هذا السياق
بنجد انه نتذكر من
الاقتصاديين اكبر المناظرين للنظام الرس
مالي جون مادر كينز اللي هو كتب في سنه
1900 32 في الثلاثينات من القرن الماضي
كتاب مهم جدا اللي هو النظريه العامه في
هذه النظريه العامه قال انه
النظام الراسمالي وهوو يعمل وهو يعمل عرضه
لازمات من داخله هذه الازمات تتمثل في
انتاج وفير جدا بفضل الكفاءه العاليه
نسبيه للنظام الرئس مالي وتضاءل الطلب على
خلفيه اعاده توزيع الدخل تركز الثروات في
ايديه عدد محدود من الناس مبوط مظبوط طيب
تحل المعضله دي ازاي قال لك لابد من تدخل
الحكومه وده كان ثوره في الفكر الاقتصادي
حيث
كان المستقر عليه او بيسمى اجماع العلماء
او الفقهاء انه النظام الراس الراسمالي
لديه القدره على تصحيح نفسه
بنفسه لابد من تدخل الدوله الحكومه حتى
وان اقتضى الامر انها تحفر الشوارع ثم
تعيد بنائها بنائها مره ثانيه لضخ دماء في
شرعين الاقتصاد احنا دلوقتي
بنستحمي الفلسفه الاقتصاديه الجديده في
السياق الحالي انك انت
عندك نظام الراسمال العالمي مازوم وشواهد
الازمه جزء منها هيكلي الجزء الثاني عام
متمثل في تباطؤ النمو
الاقتصادي
ا وبالتالي الحل انك انت تخترع اليه اليه
لضخ دماء جديده في شري الاخصا مظبوط هنا
الحروب هو الاختراع الجديد طيب هنا بقى
سؤال عندك ممكن جدا يبقى اكتر من طريقه ان
ك تطبق دوله الرفاه وتوزع على الناس وتخلق
رخاء
للجميع وهذه ليست الاليه الوحيده
انما توازنات القوه في النظام الراسمالي
وفي القلب منه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انه مركز
القوه متركز عندما اسماه اقتصادي امريكي
مرموق
جدا جون كنف للبرث تحدث عن ما يسمى المركب
الصناعي العسكري اه اه المركب الصناعي
العسكري عنده عباره عن حلف كبير جدا مقدس
او غير مقدس هو حلف بين بين شركات الصنا
الصناعيه العسكري مظبوط شركات الصناعه
وبذات الصناعات العسكريه ودول اصبحوا مع
رجال السياسه مع رجال السياسه وفي الواقع
اصبح هم اللي بيحددوا مين رجال السياسه
اللي صدروا المشهد نقطه مهمه جدا فاذا
احنا نشوف دلوقتي انه ا حدث هذا في
اوكرانيا بالمناسبه واوكرانيا اصبحت
ا يعني مضخه من
المضخات المستجده
لضخ دماء في عيون النظام الراسمالي
العالمي من خلال حرب قد يطول امد تدمر ا
في الحالتين انك انت بتدمر
اسلحه وبتدمع
ا مجتمعات باكمله بن تحتيه ومساكن ومدارس
والخر ثم تعيد بناء هذا الايه فتحقق ارباح
مضبوط منتهى العبثيه لو نظرنا الى الموضوع
انك انت ما هو الطائل ورا كل هذا غير انه
التاكيد
على
حمايه مصالح
الفئات ذات النفوذ في هذا الايه في هذا
النظام فهنا بقى لما ني شوف انا شخصيا
شايف ان الموضوع وا اذا امكن للغرب ان
يطيل امد الصراع الحالي بسخونته الحاليه
لن يتورع ان يفعل ذلك لانه زي ما بقول
المستفيد الاكبر هو القوه خصوصا واحنا
داخلين على انتخابات وشيكه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه انتخابات التثلث في
الكونجرس وانتخابات رئاسيه وهنا كلمه
ال كلمه الحقيقه يعني نقود او النفوذ
المالي للمجمع العسكري الصناعي لابد ان
يحسب له 1000 حساب عاوز استاذن حضرتك
علشان الفكره الاساسيه ما تبقى اكثر وضوحا
لاصدقائنا هل في ا ممكن بشكل موجز حضرتك
بتقول انه النظام الراس مالي الحالي بيمر
بازمه الازمه ديت ليها اسباب مؤقته او
يعني عارضه ولها اسباب هيكليه هل ممكن
يعني نشرح الفكره دي الاول يعني ببساطه
قبل ما اسال حضرتك على التداعيات ده على
الرع في غزه شوف يعني دعونا نتابع
معا تطور او رحله النظام الراسمالي
ا منذ بدايته ها طبعا هنرجع لورا خالص في
مرحله الراسماليه التجاريه يعني كانت
قايمه على اساس طرق التجاره الطويله بعد
الاكتشافات الجغرافيه انما اهم تطور ح حدث
مع الثوره الصناعيه الاولى في القرن 1800
وشويه اظبط قرن 19
اوكي وبعدين هناك حديث عن الثوره الصناعيه
ثانيه حدثت وثوره الصناعيه الثالثه حدثت
والحديث الان عن ال الرا صح الكلام طيب
الخط البياني بتاع كل هذا جور كل هذا هو
اطلاق طاقات هائله
ا للانتاج
للانتاج اصبح هناك فره شديده جدا في
الانتاج وفي المقابل هنا لا لا يتوازى
معها ازدياد الطلب على هذا الانتاج فعندك
مضله بين طرفي المقص انجاز التعبير العرض
من ناحيه والطلب من ناحيه انيه هو وفقا
للنظام الراسمالي قادر يقدر يعمل عمليه
عرض وفره في العرض مظبوط انما نتيجه
التطور في الثورات الصناعيه وكفائته في
الانتاج صحيح ولكن بسبب طبيعه النظم
الاجتماعيه والسياسيه سائده هناك
تركز متزايد متزايد في الثروه وعلى فكرهه
الكلام ده ليس من عنديي عايز
اتذكر الساده المشاهدين بواحد من اهم
الكتب
والكتاب في زمننا اللي هو توماس بيكيتي في
كتابه المشهور الرائس ماليه في القرن 21
بالمناسبه المناسبه انا كعضو في الجمعيه
الاقتصاديه الامريكيه حضرت ندوه ما جاه
القاهره في المؤتمر لا لا في المؤتمر
الثانوي في بوستون
اه سنه كام يمكن 2015 او 16 لا
اذكر
وجيش بيكيتي في سياق مناقشه كتابه سته من
كبار الاقتصاديين الامريكان وكان كل
الكلام انت راجل مركسي وافكارك واخرس كده
اي لتوماس بكتيه وانما الفكره كلها ده دول
ممثل ممثلي ما يسمى
المؤسسه المعنى الكبير للكلمه النظام
السائد يعني مظبوط يدافعوا ويدافعوا بدراء
وفي رايي تجوزوا
حدود اللياقه حقيقي انا كنت حاضر وذهلت من
فعايز اقول ايه بقى بكتي قال ايه في
الكلام ده بكيتي استعرض تطور النظام
الراسمالي على امتداد المئتي عام السابقه
لنشر كتابه وتوفر على كم هائل من البيانات
والمعلومات وقياسات اقتصاديه دقيقه جدا
وخرج بنتيجه مدهشه ان هناك تزايد للام
مساواه كاتجاه عام في ظل هذا النظام اذا
معالي الدكتور حضرتك تقصد انه باختصار انه
النظام الراسمالي اللي موجود عنده اسباب
هيكليه اساسيه بتادي الى توليد الازمات
ودي الخلل الاساسي اللي حضرتك بتشير اليه
وارجو ان تصححي لو اخطات يعني في انه
النظام قادر على تراكم الانتاج من خلال
الثورات الصناعيه والتكنولوجيا والكفاءه
في الاداء النسبي نتيجه انه في حافز دايما
لاصحاب رؤوس الاموال ان هم يربحوا صحيح
فده بيحفز على الانتاج الانتاج بيزيد لكن
المشكله نتيجه انه هذا النظام بيادي الى
تراكم الثروات في ايدين فئه محدوده جدا
بيادي الى عدم قدره الناس على الطلب لانه
الغالبيه العظمى بتبقى واقعه تحت خط الفقر
او عاجزه
عن الاست رار في شراء ما هو معروض فبدي
الى ازمات من وقت الى اخر ده هو المقصود
بالخلل الهيكلي بالاضافه للاسباب العارضه
بقى تبقى حرب هنا حرب هناك ا ازمه كورونا
سلاسل الامداد الى اخره يعني دي الاسباب
العارضه نتيجه ان احنا بنعيش واحده من
الازمات دي للنظام الراسمالي اللي هو من
2008 والى الان حضرتك بتقول النظام بيبقى
عاوز يخرج من ازمته بزياده الطلب واحد
ا يعني الاتجاهات لزياده الطلب هو خلق
الحروب مش كده ب دكتور تمام بالتالي عندنا
اوكرانيا وعندنا غز مبوط وده بالمناسبه
الموضوع اتكلم عنه كارل ماركس لما كاتب
كتابه وقال لك ازمه فائد
الانتاج ازمه فائض الانتاج من الازمات
اللصيقه بالنظام الراسمالي وكون احد معاول
هدم هذا النظام وقال كده كارل ماركس ان هو
عنده فاض انتاج اكثر مما ينبغي مزبوط مضبط
بسبب انه في النظام الراسمالي طبعا رغم
انتقادنا ليه يعتبر تطور هام جدا في ظل
بالمعيار التاريخي بالمقارنه بالنظام
السابق عليه هو النظام الاقطاعي
واطلق قوه هائله لذات الانتاج ورفع
الانتاجيه عظيم فنتج عن هذا
انه القدره على الانتاج اصبحت هائله لا
اقول غير محدو انما هائله و
الطلب الموازي لها غير موجود في ظل
اساسيات النظام الراسمالي لابد ان يتم هذا
من خلال الاسواق الاسواق لا تعمل لانه
عندك كفه بمستوى والكفه الثانيه بمستوى
تاني ف عرض عالي وطلب محد دي معضله كينز
حلها بطريقته انما الصوره الجديده هي
ابتداء الحروب الحروب ده كويس حضرك قلت
كده عشان استاذنك اوضح برض حضرك اكلمت على
كينز يمكن بعض تبعين يكون لم تصلوا الفكره
هو كينز كانت فكرته ان في اوقات الازمات
ممكن تتدخل الدول وده كان جديد زي ما
حضرتك بتقول على النظام الراس مالي اللي
بيقول انه الحكومات يكون دورها محدود فقال
لازم تتدخل حتى لو كان تدخلها ان هي تحفر
الطرق من جديد اللي هي معموله وتعيد
بنائها علشان تنشط الظ عشان بقى ركب
الصوره بشكل اكثر
اكتمالا منذ الثمانينات تسيد ما يسمى
الفكر النيوليبرالي اص ومعناه انه الدوله
تفضل في اطار ما يسمى الدوله الحارسه يعني
تحفظ الامن والنظام
العام مظبوط طيب تحل مشكله النظام الرسمال
ازاي اذا كان الدوله ليس لها ان تفعل ما
اراد كينز ان تفعله لا اعاده التوازن الى
النظام الرس مالي هنا الحروب هو الاختراع
الجديد كويس كده ولكن اود ان اؤكد نقطه
اخرى خ بالك انه برده
الوضع الحدث الحالي اقليميا في السياق
الاكبر وارتباطه بما سبق وقلناه بانه
العالم يعيش مرحله انتقاليه المرحله
الانتقاليه هناك سيد للعالم مش سيد جبيل
سيد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه خلاص
وهناك من ينتظر لكي يحتل مكانه هو الصين
في هذا الصراع لما تيجي تاخد انه الولايات
المتحده تسعى الى كذب ارض اقليمي ونفوذ
اقليمي على حساب الصين فبتحب غرضين في
واحد تدير العجله الانتاجيه بتاعتها في
مجال التدمير ثم طرد انما في النهايه في
النهايه ثم تكسب تحقق مكاسب ومن خلالها
تحصر الصين مضبوط ولكن قضيه ان الحروب
تصبح اداء اكثر الحاحا لاعاده التوازن الى
نظام الرئس وفاك ازمته تكتسب
اهميه في ظل ظاهره
جديده اللي هي العولمه الماليه العولمه
الماليه يعني ايه عولمه ماليه عيه معناها
انه فتح كل المجالات وكل المسارات لانطلاق
الاموال من بلد الى اخر عبر العالم
المؤسسات العمليه اصبحت تلعب دور اهم من
المؤسسات الصناعيه المؤسسات الماليه زي
البنوك وشركات التامين مبوط وطبعا في
حركاتها تخلق دخول هذا الدخول لا يوازيها
انتاج فمره تانيه بتعمق ازمه النظام الرس
مالي لدرجه انه ا لو حسبنا لو
حسبنا حجم الصناعه الماليه مثلا خدنا
اقتصاد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واخدنا
حجم الصناعه الماليه حجم الصناعه الماليه
داخل وبتاع ده يتجاوز
حجم الناتج المحلي الاجمالي بمعناه
المعروف وده معناه انه بالفعل في ازمه ه
تستغرق اجل يعني هي يعني لا يمكن تتحل
عايز اولا فكر اقتصادي وفكر سياسي مختلف
وبع التغير في موازين القوى داخليا لكي
تحدث هذه النقله بس انا يعني ايجت
كونفيوزد شويه استاذ حضرتك اسالك سؤال
يمكن اذا كان في اجابه لا قي وان اوضح
يعني الجزء الاولاني كان واضح انه النظام
بطبيعته تاريخيا كان بيادي الى زياده
الانتاج وبيب حث عن اسواق لتسويق هذا
الانتاج نتيجه تركز الثروات بيلاقي الناس
مش قادره تشتري لانه فقرا الثروه متركزه
في 1 2 3% فده مفهوم انما حضتك ركزت على
جانب اخر من اوجه الخلل في النظام وهو انه
ما فيش توازن في السنوات الاخيره ما بين
النشاط الانتاجي وما بين الانشطه بقى
البورصه والبنوك صحيح دي انشطه مطلوبه
ولكن توحشت فبتقول نتيجه هذا التوحش انه
بقى في دخول ضخمه واموال ضخمه اكتر بكتير
من النشاط او الاموال المتولده عن الصناعه
والزراعه ده مش بناقض ده لا ما بيتناقش
بالعكس اللي انا عايز اقوله عشان برض
الفكره تصل الساده المشاهدين انه اوكي في
التناقض الرئيسي اللي كلنا عارفين تاريخين
وتكلم عليه كارل ماركس اللي هو فائض
الانتاج فائض الانتاج كويس كده قو الانتاج
بتت وور بوتيره مذهله في ظل الرا علاقات
الانتاج
متكلسه
ده بمعنى ان مافيش قدره على الطلب ان
الطلب يوازي مبوط انك انت علاقات الانتاج
اللي هي في النهايه بتحكم عمليه توزيع
الدخل محكومه
بسيطره القله في ظل طبيعه النظام
وبالتالي بيحصل ان الدخل المتاح
للاغلبيه اقل من ان يتحول الى طلب على ما
تنتجه الاله الرس الماليه ده تناقد الرئيس
الاولاني ده بيادي الى ازمات ازمات عنما
في مصدر مستجد للازمات اللي هو التحول
الجوهري اللي حدث في ظل الراس نظام الرس
المالي بدا من الات المتحده وقى على مستوى
العالم اللي
هو العولمه الماليه العوان الماليه وتنامي
الصناعه الماليه الصناعه الماليه
اصبحت اللي هي اساسها النقود اساسها
النقود
ا كان اهم وظيفه للنقود ومبرر وجودها انها
وسيله لتسويه المبادلات تاريخيا اه دلوقتي
النقود بقى لها وجود طبيعي بذاتها لا
علاقه لها بالانتاج واصبحت اصل من الاصول
المتداوله وتخلق تحركات خطورتها كمان عبر
الحدود وبالتالي السيطره عليها اصبحت اكثر
صعوبه لانها يعني لا تعرف حدودا تقف
عندها طبعا في تفصيلات يعني فنيه
وتستدعي استحضار معادلات رياضيه
ادخل فكره ببساطه ان النظام الراس المالي
وهو ينمو في المرحله الحاليه لمرحله الع
العلامه
الماليه اصبح بيت رتب عليه نمو هائل في
حركه الاقتراض الاقتراض حركه الاقتراض من
المؤسسات الماليه بنوك وغيرها وانه
ا هذا الاقتراض يتجاوز حدود الحصافه
الائتمانيه والجداره الائتمانيه كما شهدنا
في ازمه
2008 وبناء على ذلك يحدث انهيار مالي هذا
الانهيار المالي
او الازمه الماليه كما تسمى بيعتبر من
النتائج التي ولدها نظام الراسمالي في
المرحله الحاليه من داخله فاصبح عندك
عاملين مؤثرين في ح العامل الاول اللي
سميناه فائض الانتاج فائض الانتاج العمل
الثاني هو توحش الصناعه الماليه
واندلاع ازمات ماليه من داخل الظام وده
طبعا يعني كان له علاجات كتيره قيلت ان
انما لم يؤخذ بها لانها ليست على هواء
يعني الازمه الماليه العالميه مثلا دي حلت
على حساب مين على حساب المواطن العادي انه
يدعم الشركات اللي اجرمت مظبوط بال مظبوط
فده حتى خلق ما نسميه احنا يدعمهم باموال
دافعه الضرائب مظبوط وبتالي من جيوب وخلق
ما يحذر منه الاقتصاديون اللي هي
فكره الخطر المعنوي انك انت لما الخطر
الاخلاقي كمان مظبوط تكافئ مرتكب الخطا
بتعويض تمادي في ارتكاب الخط بالمناسبه
يعني في موضوع الهشاشه الماليه ودور
الصناعه الماليه ك اليه من
اليات تكرر الازمات اتذكر ان واحد من اهم
الاقتصاديين ا اسمه هيمن منسكي هيمن منسكي
له نظريه شهيره جدا اسمها نظريه الهشاشه
الماليه او فرديه الهشاشه الماليه او
فرضيه عدم الاستقرار المالي موجزها انه
النظام الراسمالي و هيعمل
واليات الصناعه الماليه تخلق ازمات من
داخلها لانها بتؤدي الى الافراط في
الاقتراض بدون اساس اقتصادي او ائتماني
لعمليه الاقتراض الى ان نصل الى مرحله
القشه التي تقسم ظهر البعير كما حدث في
ازمه 2008 وطبقا لحيم منسكي ازمه 2008
ليست اخر
الازمات فيبقى عندي نوعين مصدرين ل خلل
داخل النظام الرسمي فائض الانتاج مع وجود
تركز في الثروات فيبقى دايما في مشكله
ركود ان ما فيش طلب والامر الثاني اللي هو
توحش الصناعات الماليه البورصات والبنوك
اخذه الاعتبار ان السبب الثاني ده بيغذي
الاولاني من ناحيه زياده تركز الثروه لانه
حل المشكله طبقا لتوازنات القوه بياتي على
حساب عموم الناس انت كده شرح لي دي دي
نقطه مهمه لانه انا كنت معتقد طالما بقى
في فلوس كتيره ممكن الفلوس الكتيره دي في
الصناعه الماليه تشتري فقض الانتاج بس
اللي حاصل انه الصناعه الماليه دي بتادي
الى دخول ضخمه لكن متركزه برض في عدد
محدود من ايدين الاثر في الواقع اصبحت احد
مناسبات اعاده توزيع الدخل
منص الحال والفقراء الى الاغنياء دي عاوزه
حلقه تانيه يا معالي الدكتور لكن انا عاوز
استاذن حضرتك ان انا اختم برقم انه طوال
الوقت على مدار السنين الماضيه اجمالي ما
يقترض
العالم اكثر من ثلاثه اضعاف ما ينتجه
العالم يعني لو كان الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي للعالم مجمعا حوالي 100 ترليون
فاحنا اكث من 300 و350 ترليون والتفسير
ذلك كالتالي انه الصناعه الماليه الاداه
بتاعتها الاساسيه هي
النقود بعد ان كانت النقود اهم وظائفها
على الاطلاق في البدايه انها وسيله لتسويه
المعاملات بين
الاطراف اصبحت وظيفتها انها مخزن للقيمه
وبالتالي وسيله للمضاربه اذا اذنت ليه
حضرتك انه الدكتور
جوده ادانا اطلاله كبيره وهي اطلاله عميقه
يعني اذا اذلني الخصها انه في ظل النظام
الراس مالي اللي بيحكم العالم احنا عندنا
وجهين للخلل خلل كان تاريخي واشار اليه
الفيلسوف الشهير كارل ماركس انه هذا
النظام رغم مزاياه وكفائته لانه عنده
مشكله عنده قدره على خلق انتاج ضخم جدا في
كل القطاعات لكن مع خلق هذا الانتاج اصحاب
رؤوس الاموال بتترك الثروه في ايديهم اذا
تركزت الثروه والاموال في اي عدد قليل
يبقى الاغلبيه مش هيكون لديها اموال هتكون
عاجزه عن شراء ما ينتجه الاثرياء فيحدث
عمليه ركود وازمات اقتصاديه بانتظام ده
كان اول خلل اضيف الى هذا الخلل التاريخي
خلل جديد وهو تركيز الدول الراسماليه على
النشاط المالي بكثره فبدل ما تبقى
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا وبريطانيا مشغوله
بالزراعه والصناعه والانتاج الحقيقي بقت
مشغوله بالصناعات الماليه والصناعات
الماليه بكل انشطتها بورصه وبنوك وتامين
والشركات ديت نتيجه التوحش هذا النشاط
وطبعا منتجاته وتفاصيله والمشتقات الماليه
اللي هي حاجه غريبه جدا جدا يعني تستحق
علامات استفهام في عمليه احد اوجه الخلل
عمليه اقراض بلا حساب وقرض يخلق قرض
النتيجه انه البنوك دي ايضا بتنهار
والاسواق بتنهار من وقت لاخر وعاده بيتم
علاج اوجه الخلل بالابقاء على هذه
المؤسسات لان هي عصب النظام كله ذ ار تو
بيك تو فيل اكبر بكثير من ان تسقط اذا
سقطت ينهار النظام فا اموال دافعي الضرائب
بتمول هذه الشركات حتى تبقى وتعيد الكار
مره
اخرى استاذن حضرتك ان انت قلت انه نتيجه
هذا الخلل ونتيجه الركود بيلجا الى انشطه
متعدده منها الحروب
كوسيله مؤكده لتجديد النشاط الاقتصادي
يعني بدل ما كان الاقتصاد البريطاني بيقول
انه الدوله ممكن تتدخل بنشاط اقتصادي على
اساس تنشط او تنقذ الدوله من الركود مثلا
ببناء مشروعات بنيه تحتيه لا وبمناسبه
ومناسبه اهم مشروعات البنيه التحتيه اللي
حصلت في الولايات المتحده حصلت في
الثلاثينات من القرن الماضي راز ولا زال
امريكا عايش عليه لغايه النهارده شبكه
التوره الهائله والكباري والى اخره تطبيقا
لنظريه كينز اللي هي في فتره اللي هي
الصفقه الصفقه الجديده الصفقه الجديده
لروزفلت انه في خلل فينقذ هذا الخلل بانه
يعمل بنيه تحتيه ضخمه جدا على فكره كان في
لقاء ما بين كينز وراز فلت فاني يعني لطيف
جدا لانه الرئيس قال انا سمعت كلام معقد
جدا ما فهمتش منه بس انا فهمت يعني انه
عاوزن اعمل بنيه تحتيه كان في لقاء ما بين
الاثنين يعني فلكن بدل ما بيعملوا بنيه
تحتيه وهم في حاجه البنيه التحتيه بقي
الجو الى تحت ضغط شبكات المصالح الى فكره
الحروب بالمناسبه انا كان عندي يعني ارقام
استاذنك ان انا اقولها يعني ا اتفضل مفيده
اه انا انا انا فوجئت وانا بستطعم
ال يعني علاقه الولايات المتحده بالحرب
انها امه لا تضع السلاح ابدا فوجدت ان هم
ا وفقا لاكثر من احصاء في ال 200 سنه اللي
فاتت حربه 188 حرب ما بين حرب كبيره وحرب
صغيره يعني تقريبا كل سنه حرب 188 حرب في
200 سنه
موازنات يه واحده عشان الحروب اه حروب 188
حربا في 200 سنه اوكي بس بعد ما بدات بدا
الدوله كويس كده اه طبعا لا قبل ما بدا
دوله خلي بالك قبل ما تبقى دوله ايوه قبل
ما دوله يعني اللي هي ذكرنا بمحادثه على
ارض فلسطين اليوم مساله مهمه جدا جدا جدا
موقف
المستوطنين اللي هم سكان المسمين البيض
اللي نزحوا الى امريكا من اوروبا اساسا من
السكان الاصليين اللي هم اطلقوا عليهم من
خلال دعايه هلود الهنود الحمر والكلام ده
وحصل حرب اباده ده موضوع منهج جدا
و يعني كتب التاريخ الجديده بسميها ها
اللي هم المؤرخين والجدد بيعيدوا قراءه
المشهد في تلك المرحله
وتفاصيل كثيره جدا لكن انا عايز اقوله دي
دي ممكن تسميها الحرب الاساس وج بعديه بقى
حرب تانيه اللي حرب الاهليه وبعد كده بدات
الاله تشتغل وبعدين نت نحسب ال 188 اللي
هي واقفه عند 2015 ولا 2014 انا جزيل
الشكر لك معالي الدكتور وه هي زاويه جديده
ولكن هذه الزاويه مقلقه لانه معنى كده انه
ممكن هذا اللوبي يغذي فكره اشتعال الصراع
اكثر بحيث لا يكون قاصرا على غزه ودي
مساله تحتاج ان نتابعها مع حضرتك في حلقات
اخرى ان شاء الله باذن الله جزيل الشكر
وشكرا جدا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم مع الدكتور
جوده ان شاء الله في حلقات اخرى باذن الله